Scot Osterweil: Starting with my
routine and that's what I'm
welcoming you to the colloquium.
I'm Scot Osterweil, creative
director of the MIT education
arcade. Welcome to tonight's
colloquium and just to again to
go over the ground rules with
zoom. We run this as a webinar,
which means that the members of
the CMS graduate program and
faculty are on as panelists just
so that they can participate in
the conversation after the
presentation. If we recognize
you as somebody from the MIT
community, we will try to
promote you to panelists as
well. If you remain a guest,
you're also welcome to
participate. We just asked you
to ask questions in the q&a. But
you're more than welcome to be
here this weekend, every week
for the colloquium. with that I
will turn things over to
Professor Vivek Bald who's going
to actually introduce tonight's
colloquium.
Vivek Bald: Thank you, Scot.
Well, it's it's really a
pleasure to be able to, to
welcome Mauricio Cordero to the
colloquium. It's been a pleasure
to to have morito as part of the
CMS community for the last few
years and just a little about
Mauricio. He has worked in the
arts and underground scene since
the 1980s. He established the
fanzine caution and served as
the education coordinator and
program director at the
Institute of Contemporary Art in
Boston. In France, he opened his
own art gallery in Tours
returning to the US he served as
executive director at the
revolving Museum, and was also a
founding director of mill number
five, an indoor Victorian
streetscape, which I'd like to
hear a bit more about in the
q&a. Cordero now teaches comics
primarily and is a part time
lecturer at MIT. He's currently
teaching making comics and
sequential art, and lecturing in
the visuals story graphic novel.
His work has been published in
double nickels forever. dollars
and cents. MIT's graphics comic
series and Fashion Institute of
Technology's black stories
matter. BORDERx, A Crisis in
Graphic Detail is available at
all major online retailers and
through the website. borderx.com
and we're gonna hear about
BORDERx.
Mauricio Cordero: Okay.
Oh, I think I've lost audio. You
can hear me. Great. Okay, so I'm
just gonna let this roll. Yeah.
Hi,
I'm Mauricio Cordero. I'm a
lecturer at MIT. I teach a
course on comics production. I'm
also the founder and the editor
of BORDERx. Today, I'll be in
conversation with Professor
James Paradis, as well as
Professor Warren Binford, who is
the president and the founder of
Project Amplify. We'll also hear
from several of the artists who
contributed to this volume. And
first we'll hear a special
message from someone whose
actions really inspired me to
take action that Senator Jeffrey
Merkley from Oregon.
Senator Jeff Merkley: Welcome to
today's presentation of the
BORDERx project. I'm Oregon
Senator Jeff Merkley. And the
topic is one I'm personally very
invested in. Two years ago, just
days after Attorney General Jeff
Sessions announced the
administration's zero tolerance
policy, which criminalize
refugees and purposefully
traumatized children for fleeing
persecution, and unspeakable
violence. I flew down to the
border to see the situation for
myself. I walked through a
Customs and Border Protection
patrol station, where I saw rows
of chainlink cages filled with
young children. I stopped in
front of one where young boys
were lining up by hike the
youngest in front. He was just
knee high to a grasshopper maybe
four years old at most. I
couldn't believe what I saw in
that facility. I could not
believe that our government the
US government was deliberately
traumatizing children, ripping
them out of their parents arms
to discourage refugee families
from seeking safe harbor in the
United States. It still haunts
me today, it should haunt every
American. I also went to visit
another facility where I'd heard
that hundreds of boys perhaps as
many as 1000 were being held who
had been separated from their
parents. I couldn't imagine 1000
boys incarcerated in that former
Walmart and I couldn't imagine
the experiences they'd gone
through the hands of our
government. I wanted to find out
the details. The onsite manager
agreed to come out side and talk
to me. But instead, he called
the police to have me escorted
off the policy of the property.
Well, when he did that millions
of Americans were watching on
Facebook Live. And those
Americans wondered, just as I
was wondering, what is our
government hiding behind those
locked doors? Never before would
I have believed that our
government, the United States of
America would plunge ahead with
a strategy of traumatizing
children deliberately, but it
was real. By the end of the
year, more than 15,000 refugee
children were held in camps
across our nation. Today, at
this moment, our American
government has still been unable
to reunite more than 600 of them
with their parents. And all of
those children. All those many
thousands still have to live
with the trauma of their
experiences inflicted at the
hands of our government. But
child separation was only the
beginning of the Trump
administration's war on
refugees. As we all know, there
are many more pieces to that
policy. But it's up to us now,
with Trump heading out the door,
to confront the pain and
suffering to do all we can to
remedy the pain and suffering of
those children and do all we can
to restore fairness and justice
to the immigration system. We
need to ensure that policies
like child separation never,
ever happen again. I know that
that's why many of you have come
to this gathering today. Thank
you. Thank you for working to
understand the cruelty unleashed
our southern border, and how we
can work together to end it.
Working together, let's relight
Lady Liberty's torch.
Jim Paradis: Why don't you say
something about what got to, you
know, thinking about comics and
borders?
Mauricio Cordero: The origin was
really anger and rage that I was
feeling. And I hadn't felt this
angry since I was a teenager,
you know, rebelling against
Reagan and Bush. And living
growing up in DC and around
politics. I mean, that was or
meat and potatoes down there. We
thought about politics all the
time, even as a high school
student. And, you know, back
then the rage was directed
towards music. So I realized
that, you know, if I was going
to bring any sort of substantial
record or evidence of my
rebellion, it had to be in the
form of a comic book. And so I
started to directly contact a
few friends and say, you know,
hey, what do you think about
this, and the response was
overwhelmingly positive.
Jim Paradis: But I was just
curious if there was some set of
episodes or something that set
this off.
Mauricio Cordero: I think the
the first incident was Senator
Jeff Merkley, trying to get into
the detention camp and being
turned away. And it wasn't at
all what he said on camera as he
was turned away. It was the
absence of footage from inside
the border camp, seeing how much
the political structure in our
government had caved into this
new doctrine. That was very, I
feel racist, very anti asylum.
These are people who are in most
cases fleeing a situation that
is unlivable untenable for them
in their families, and they're
trying to make a better life.
But, as we know, the person who
is in the white house right now
referred to them as rapists and
murderers. Some drug dealers,
not having a view inside the
camps concerned me knowing that
just about everything that comes
out of that person's mouth is
either projection or just a lie.
My tweets weren't going
anywhere. And certainly didn't
satisfy that rage. And so, you
know, that DIY punk rock spirit
came back to me. And I said,
Well, I've got to make all this
concrete and found out about
Project Amplify, who published
testimony of migrants that were
presented in Flores versus Barr.
Jim Paradis: The construction of
artistic work requires a kind of
a suspension of rage and some of
the, the emotions that might
lead to starting it. So how did
that work?
Mauricio Cordero: Well, when I
opened up the project to the
world at large, I realized I was
getting a lot of rage back. And
that's when I installed a ban on
the word Trump. And that is
where the rage turned into
productivity, you know, it
started with rage, and then
quickly became compassion. And
then I realized I had to steer
the ship,
Jim Paradis: You can only raise
so much in a piece before
becomes too literal to be art,
and then becomes a form of
almost propaganda or something
like that. There's this long
history of Americans trying to
figure out how they're going to
exist in a world that is way
more complicated than some may
understand. As far as
indigenous, there are hundreds
of indigenous people on every
continent, of every continent of
the globe. And this is one focus
that you have on this particular
location, but it it sort of
stands does it not for, you
know, a kind of universal
problem that has to do with
borders?
Mauricio Cordero: Absolutely. In
at the very beginning, I made
the decision to include science
fiction, and fiction, as one of
the sections that we would have
in the final work. To get to the
universal truths in this
struggle. We need fiction, we
need science fiction, we need
allegories that go beyond the
headlines and beyond this
moment, and even beyond this
planet, in. And so I really
enjoyed curating that section
and finding the artists, it was
wonderful to get so many
different points of view looking
inward. And modalities, you
know, science fiction, straight
documentary, some report.
Jim Paradis: So maybe in person,
since you're, you're bridging on
some of these these questions,
maybe say a little more about
the process of making this? How
does a person decide and then go
about making a collection like
this?
Mauricio Cordero: Yeah, well,
when you get to the point where
the rage outweighs common sense,
I think that's, that's where you
get started, I found myself kind
of alone at the beginning. And
then people did step up as the
project grew. So I guess the
first step is deciding you're
going to do it, and defining it,
and scale it to what your
abilities are.
Or the way I did it was naively
scaling it way above my
abilities and having to grow
into those abilities. So, you
know, I have experience in
producing comics and putting
them together, I know all the
tech specs, etc. But there's a
much greater learning curve in
terms of hurting 70
contributors.
Jim Paradis: And these
contributors sometimes, I mean,
a comic is, is not always done
just by a single author. And
generally it's just done by
there's an anchor, there's a
colorist or someone who deals
with the the actual narratives,
the bubbles and all the things
that so how did that all work
out that it did most of these
get done by I noticed that
almost all of them have
multiple, multiple constructors
that are there multiple people
involved.
Mauricio Cordero: Right, well
that was a part of what took a
lot of legwork at the beginning
was playing matchmaker. Now,
there were people that came with
a team, and we're ready to go. A
few in a few cases, there was
existing work that we could just
take and reprint where the
artists had all the rights to
reprint. So that happened. But I
did play matchmaker and really
took time to read scripts, pass
them along to penciller are
artists. And, you know, at that
point, we determined whether the
artists would take on the entire
project, or if I had to go out
and find a letter or colorist,
I'm so really trying to find
what a comfortable or doable
workload was for each
participant. There are a few
people that were just really
helpful. Raul Torres, for
example, was one person who
stepped up and helped a lot with
the editing. And he got a lot of
teams together found a lot of
tied up a lot of loose ends.
Jim Paradis: I'm curious about
the organization, which I think
is very, very effective. But you
have the exhibits, which are
sort of, you know, reviews,
interviews and things of that
sort that were captured. These
are testimonials. But then you
have the response. And you have
the context, and then
ruminations and then a series of
posters. So I'm just curious
about that, that collection,
which I think is a rich variety
of possibilities for this this
form.
Mauricio Cordero: As the work
began to arrive, a sub-pattern
emerge, and the patterns
strengthened over time into what
seemed like for good sections
for the book. The four sections
are the exhibits the response,
the context and ruminations. So
I felt that the factual and most
heart wrenching work should
appear at the beginning of the
book to establish what what
we're talking about when we say
migrant crisis. These exhibits
are based on verbatim
transcripts of migrant
experiences in the detention
camp. And these testimonies were
presented to the Supreme Court
in ongoing Flores vs Barr case,
to mitigate the just devastating
nature of these testimonies. I
chose to highlight agents and
agencies that are working to
create hope by aiding migrants
in in the field. And so the
response section collects a few
of those stories. Then the
context section collects
personal reflections and
historic accounts to try to
offer a broad contextual
background for the volume. The
last section, the ruminations
offers fiction, allegory
metaphor, and adaptation to get
at some of the underlying themes
and universal truths that we can
find in the crisis. And closing
out the volume. There's a small
section of posters that were
created, especially for the
collection in the vein of sort
of works, Works Progress
Administration, sort of war-era
posters,
Jim Paradis: Do you have any
kind of expectations for the
impact of a piece of work like
this? Or is or is it kind of
more diffused? So kind of
cultural, just awareness? Or how
do you how do you think about
impact,
Mauricio Cordero: One impact I'd
hoped for is precisely what
we're talking about today.
sharing this model, with the
public in hopes of inspiring the
replication for other social
causes. Another is to create a
graphic history of this moment,
so that we don't forget these
atrocities that are being
carried out in the name of the
US. Also, bearing witness to the
suffering and torment endured by
the subjects of in this book,
who've they've got so much to
offer, or society yet they're
treated like criminals for
seeking a better life. Asylum is
not a crime. Crossing the border
illegally is a misdemeanor, yet
it seems like they're being
punished for a felony or some
other serious crime. We set out
to help a nonprofit. And the one
we decided on the south Texas
Human Rights Center is a really
good example of an organization
with an extremely modest budget,
and they're creating a real
benefit to society, and the
funds we've collected, and the
proceeds that we continue to
generate, have gone to help them
carry out their mission. And
we'll hear a bit more about the
subtext of Human Rights Center
later on in the presentation.
Jim Paradis: How does
distribution work and things of
that sort?
Mauricio Cordero: The question
about distribution format came
up immediately, should I try to
find a publisher and potentially
wait years to see any sort of
result, or take a risk and self
published and rely mostly on
word of mouth, I chose the
latter. And despite many
difficulties, delays,
complications, some of them due
to COVID. In the end, I think it
was the best choice. By using a
print on demand service, we had
a lower risk than vanity
printing. And we were able to
get the volume into production,
eight months after the start of
the project. So that's eight
months to contact all the
contributors, create the
content, edit, design, layout,
and get it to print and
distribution. Also, by serving
as the publisher, we can
continue to generate profit,
which goes to fund the South
Texas Human Rights Center. And
the title is currently being
distributed worldwide. So it's
available for about the same
cost as buying it here in the
US. So I'd say the benefits are
similar to the traditional
publishing route, but with a
much higher revenue stream and
lower risks.
Jim Paradis: It gives, it sort
of gives a new meaning to public
art, you know, the creation of
and collaborating together to
try to address issues that are
really outstanding and urgent,
and we need more of this not
less. This is a pioneering
effort, I would say, just from
what I know about comics, so
you've kind of invented a new
process. It's,it's, it's a, it's
a really brilliant project. So I
think, you know, very, very glad
that it happened. And, you know,
I hope, I hope you continue.
Mauricio Cordero: Let's get
started.
So, Warren, can you tell me a
little bit about the origin of
Project Amplify? how it got
started, white got started, when
it got started and what the
mission is.
Warren Binford: Yes, Project
Amplify was started in the
summer of 2019, after
approximately a dozen of us left
the clinic Border Patrol
facility where we had discovered
over 350 children being kept in
a windowless warehouse, a
loading dock, jail cells, and
tents in the desert. The
children were hungry, they were
filthy. They have been severely
neglected. There was no one
supervising them. They were
sleeping on concrete floors,
concrete blocks next to open
toilets. They had been taken
away from, you know, family
members, and and were basically
left alone to take care of each
other. But there was widespread
illness, there was a flu and
respiratory illness that was
going around, there was a
licensed destination. And we
went to the public about what we
have discovered because the
situation has gotten so
dangerous and so extreme under
under President Trump's
administration in the year
leading up to that summer of
2019. At least seven children
have died in government custody
or shortly after they had been
released from government
custody, and we were afraid that
more children were going to die.
The President denounced it as
fake news said that our accounts
were grossly exaggerated. He and
Vice President Pence assured
that the children were well
taken care of which was not
true. And they put Vice
President Pence both on the
Sunday talking head shows and
then Air Force two and flew him
down to Texas, where he toured
another facility. They dress the
children and government issued
brightly colored sweat suits and
then have the children pose for
the camera and wave and give a
thumbs up that they were being
well taken care of. And we
realized that there was a false
counter narrative that was being
advanced at the highest levels
of government and wondered how
it was that we can counter that
narrative so that these
children's experiences and their
histories were not erased. And
we decided to create a website
and post all of the publicly
available testimonies of the
children on that website so that
any member of the public who
wanted to inform themselves
could go and read the children's
accounts, and, and discover for
themselves what the truth was
what the children said, in their
own words. And then we call out
to artists, and writers and
musicians and everyday Americans
and ask them to read the
children's accounts and find
ways to amplify their voices.
What was different in 2019, than
previous years? Yeah, so I
started visiting the camps in
2017. You know, sometimes
children are in cages, and
sometimes they're in jail cells.
So it's hard for people to
understand that there are many
facilities in which these
children are being kept. And
none of them that I visited are
appropriate for children. And
what was different about what
happened in the last four years,
is the number of children who
are being held the length of
time in which they were being
held, the number of children who
were being removed from their
families, including their
parents, and the the level of
abuse that we're experiencing,
and the number of deaths prior
to the children who died in
2018. And 2019, no child had
died in the, you know, no
traffic, no immigrant child in
our childhood migration and died
in government custody in almost
a decade. And we saw
approximately seven children
that we know of, you know, there
may have been more, but we don't
have seven children who had died
in the year leading up to our
visit to plant in June 2019. So
that's what we were saying
conditions so bad that children
were literally dying. And, and
it was theater last year, a lot
in 2019, there were
approximately 69,000 children
who have been detained by the US
government. And that was a
significantly increased number,
from what we've seen in years
past.
Mauricio Cordero: So are they
committing a crime by crossing
the border?
Warren Binford: It depends. When
someone comes to United States
for the purpose of claiming
asylum, they are not required to
have documentation. So people
who are coming to the United
States to claim asylum for that
purpose are not committing a
crime, they have the right to do
that, under US law, they have
the right to do that under
international law. However, if
someone is coming to the United
States for the purpose of, for
example, getting a job, they are
committing a crime, and that
crime is a misdemeanor, it's the
equivalent of playing your radio
too loud or music too loud. And
so what that means is when the
Trump administration implemented
the zero tolerance policy and
said, we're going to take
children away from anybody who
crosses the border, you know,
without consideration of a, you
know, whether or not they're
coming for asylum, they were
essentially violating the law.
And then when they took children
away from people who weren't
here, finding asylum, but for
jobs, literally, they were
taking their children away for a
misdemeanor that was suitable
and playing their music too
loud. starting in January 2019,
they started to implement what's
called the migrant protection
protocols, also known as
remained in Mexico. And, and
many of the children and
families that normally would be
in the United States, while
their asylum claims are being
heard, are being sent to these
very dangerous border towns in
Mexico, where that are
controlled by gangs that are
controlled by cartels, where
there's a lot of human
trafficking. Remember that
Mexico is one of the lead source
countries for human trafficking
in America. And rather than keep
the children in the United
States, with their family, their
parents, other loved ones,
they're sending them to these
really dangerous border towns,
and then keeping them there for
what could be a 2, 3, 4, 5 year
process and march 2020, the
Trump administration basically
started to block all arrivals to
the United States, and blamed it
on COVID, which is so ironic,
because this administration
doesn't recognize, you know, the
severity or danger of COVID. The
hundreds of children that we do
know about are actually being
kept in black box locations,
such as hotels, and so we're
having a really hard time
tracking those children isn't
worse, you know, being an
attempt in Mexico with your
parents for several years. You
know, we're what's likely to be,
you know, several years or is it
worse to be separated from your
parents for, you know, 89 days,
which is the average was the
average under the Trump
administration until recently,
and kept in Border Patrol
facilities you know, or Walmart,
but then reunited with your
family after that. And and I
guess what I come down is that
both of these are horrible. And
neither one of them is
acceptable. And what we really
need to do is under a new
administration, and with the new
Congress, we need to create
legal protections to make sure
that the brutality that children
have been subjected to under
this administration never
happens again. And I've already
spoken with Senator Merkley's
office about working together to
draft legislation that makes
sure that this never happens.
Again, we need to get to the
root problem, part of the root
problem is, is trying to support
security and the children's home
countries so that they don't
need to migrate. But for those
who do need to migrate and make
sure that they are treated
humanely throughout the asylum
process, we also, you know,
Michael Bochenek of Human Rights
Watch, and I also are working on
a policy piece that describes
how to undo all the damage
that's been done by the Trump
administration. And we hope to
have that published in January.
And I mean, we're already seeing
such a severe drop in students,
foreign students coming to the
United States to study and it's
a huge brain drain, frankly,
that that's something that that
you you know, this you work at
MIT, you know, this is something
that we've relied on for years,
which is, you know, an open
academy globally, so that people
could come here, and then there
could be a vibrant exchange of
ideas. This is what the whole
Fulbright program is about. And
so they really are, you know,
creating a tremendous
impediment to enrichment of
America by having, you know, an
open flow of global ideas and
global talent. So, you know,
what we know, is that when you
isolate people, they go quite
mad. You know, we see this with
the unabomber. We see this this
with other isolationists that
human beings are inherently
social creatures, who need
interaction with others, we need
interactions in order to be
exposed to fresh ideas, we need
interaction with others in order
to inspire creativity. We need
to not lock ourselves up in a
basement for so many reasons. I
mean, literally, we're already
going quite mad, just, you know,
in in the months that we've been
in lockdown, and in the months
that we've tried to, you know,
change to a closed society, when
you look at what's happening as
we create these echo chambers,
and how insane family members
are, that we've talked to for
years, but now that we are
starting to close ourselves off
and not engage with people who
have different ideas than then
we have, it has become so
unhealthy and so toxic. That I
think it's, it gives us a vision
of what life would be like in
the United States, if we
continue to further isolate
ourselves, both as a country and
as different groups within the
country who have political ideas
that might not be consistent
with others.
Mauricio Cordero: Why? or How
can art help? Yeah.
Warren Binford: It's so
interesting, because I'm not an
artist, I'm not particularly
creative. And yet, I can look at
a work of art, and feel it
resonate. In every pore of my
being, there are times when I
can't read another sad story.
And yet I could look at a
picture and be completely open
and absorb the story, or the
image that that art conveys.
artists can simply create an
image, create a sound, tell a
story. And that can silence the
noise and allow a truth to be
known. And and I appreciate the
courage that they have to do
things like read the stories of
the you know, read the
declarations, the testimonies of
the children who have been
abused at the border, allow that
trauma into their being and to
transform the child's trauma.
Through secondary exposure,
trauma of the artists in order
to help get the children's
stories out is
Mauricio Cordero: the news media
in particular, helping the
situation at the border.
Warren Binford: So so I have to
say that I think that the news
media has really helped us with
certain getting the truth out
about certain stories, so the
separation of children from
their parents and making sure
that the public knew about
children who were being abused
and The Clint Border Patrol
facility and neglected down
there, the media has really
disappointed me as far as, you
know, educating the public about
what was going on with the
children who are being sent to
Mexico who are not Mexican. And,
you know, including many who
don't speak Spanish, I wish that
the media understood better,
that the children in Mexico are
in reconstructive us custody,
because they have asylum
hearings pending, you know, that
they are asylum and to the
refugees basically, and, and
that they 89% of them have
families or other loved ones in
the United States who can keep
caring, take care of them in
regular homes and send them to
schools, while their asylum
claims are being heard. And
instead, they're being kept
intense. And, you know, car
cartels control the areas, you
know, to have the children that
a colleague of mine and his team
interviewed. They were killed
before the interviewers plane
had even left the ground, you
know, in Tijuana, and so that
these children's lives are at
risk there, they're not
receiving access to education,
which they have a right to. And
there is the likelihood that
they will remain there. For
years, you know, the entire
world has recognized that
children have a right to all
these things that children have
a right to family integrity,
that children have a right to be
in a safe and secure environment
that they have a right to, to
education, and that they have a
right to, you know, safety, you
know, from prosecution, and to
be free of abuse and neglect.
And whether you're talking about
the US facilities in the United
States that I visited, or
whether you talk about, you
know, the camps and other
facilities where children are
being sent by the US government,
to Mexico, none of these meet
the children's rights that have
been recognized under the UN
Convention on the Rights of the
Child which has been ratified by
every every country in the
world. But one, the people who
have been, you know, who have
seen border acts and have seen
some of the other projects have
expressed so much appreciation,
and such a strong emotional
response to these different
projects. And they're so
appreciative of all the artists
who have contributed to them, I
think that they have played a
key role in helping to motivate
people to get off the boat, and
to call for a change in
leadership. I think that, you
know, the mistreatment of
children in migration and their
families has been identified as
a key issue that is akin to, you
know, suburban women in in, in,
in swing states. And I think
that to the extent that those
women, those voters find out
about come to understand what's
been done to these children and
their families, that it can have
a positive impact on the
selection. So every artist,
every musician, every writer,
everyone who has put up the
children's one of the children's
quotes on a long, long sign
people who have done street art
in in Philadelphia and
elsewhere, the sky writers who
have sent messages, you know, in
the skies behind their planes,
during major public events, I
think all of these people should
know that, at best, they may
have contributed to change the
outcome of this election. And in
doing so changing the course of
history, they have helped to
make sure that there is an
accurate history of what was
done to these children. And in
doing so they have not only
honored our nation in making
sure that we understand what
we've done, and you know, and
what we have tragically allowed
to happen. But that these
children's identities and
experiences are honored and
amplified. I just appreciate so
much the role that comics have
played and the comics artists
have played when I first reached
out and asked the public to do
this. I did not imagine the
overwhelming support that we've
seen from comics artists, you
know, from South Park to BORDERx
to the illustration, the
children's book and I am so
grateful to all of you for
contributing your your talents.
So thank you so much for
amplifying your voices.
Mauricio Cordero: And thank you
so much. When I started BORDERx
I had not yet heard of Project
Amplify it was really the the
linchpin that brought a lot of
people in that couldn't commit
to longer pieces. And it really
helped us get those first few
comics that then grew out the
rest of the project. So thank
you so much for all your work
with Project Amplify and
everything else that you're
doing. Oh, thank you, Maurcio.
Warren Binford: I appreciate you
so much.
Mauricio Cordero: You're
welcome.
Eddie Canales: Hello, this is
Eddie Canales. I'm the director
of the South Texas Human Rights
Center that is located in Brooks
county and falfurrias is the
county seat of Brooks County.
Brooks county has demonstrated
to be over the last 10 years,
the apex of migrant deaths. And
we have a humanitarian crisis of
margen bodies and scelta remains
being recovered and Brooks
county this year it has been to
date has been 3032 bodies that
have been as killed the remains
that have been recovered. This
demonstrates a humanitarian
crisis that exists on the US
Mexico border. And in that note,
that crisis is is demonstrated
by the BORDERx comic book
anthology in comic book form.
And it has been well received by
a lot of my colleagues and
members of our organization.
Individuals and our
universities, NGOs that are are
reviewing and taking the
ontology and using it in their
classroom and using it to
educate the community and also
decision makers and stakeholders
without the BORDERx, we would
not have the tool that that has
been developed by Mauricio
Cordero and his colleagues in
terms of highlighting the crisis
that exists at the border and
the different issues that that
are, are very prevalent. Thank
you very much for your attention
on this short video. If you need
any questions called our look at
the South Texas human rights in
our Facebook page and our
website, thank you very much.
David Lasky: Hi, my name is
David Lasky. I am a graphic
novelist. I've been making
graphic novels and comics for
about 30 years for BORDERx, I
adapted the testimony of a 15
year old girl who was detained
seeking entrance into the US and
placed in giant cage with many
other children at the Clint
border facility near El Paso,
Texas. In one page, I tried to
give a visual Look at her
experience, and amplify her
voice in this way. Because I am
outraged that the US is
separating children and parents
putting children in cages and
then not able to reunite them
with parents. It's disgusting.
And as an artist, you know, I
wanted something I could do
besides just signing internet
petitions. So this was a way to
use my skills to try to help and
I hope it will make a difference
for children like this girl just
want a better life in our
country.
Brian DeLay: My name is Brian
DeLay, I teach the history of
the US Mexican Borderlands at UC
Berkeley. And I had the good
pleasure of meeting Mauricio
Cordero last year in 2019 at
Stanford University where I was
a fellow and we got to talking
about our shared love of comic
books. I been a big fan my whole
life and managed a comic store
for a few years before I went to
graduate school. And he
mentioned this remarkable
exciting project that he had
been spearheading border acts to
raise awareness and, and and
raise money. For me it writes on
the border. And he invited me to
think about whether or not I
might be able to come up with
some kind of a short piece based
in history. And after thinking
about it for a while, I decided
that it would be interesting to
write a short script about a
remarkable Mexican figure. He
was a general and a scientist
named  Manuel de Mier y Terán.
And in the early 1830s, he tried
to convince his superiors in the
Mexican government that
something terrible was about to
happen in Texas, that the
colonists that the country had
invited into Texas, we're going
to rebel and that the country
that Mexico is going to lose
Texas forever. And he failed. He
failed to convince them to take
the action that they needed and
he killed himself. So it seemed
like a relevant story for
thinking about the crisis on the
border today. Because in Manuel
de Mier y Terán's time it was an
immigration crisis. It's just
that the immigration crisis was
coming from the United States.
So I came up with the script and
to my great delight, Mauricio
agreed to do the artwork
himself. And so the finished
product is the piece in BORDERx
called Texas killed him. And it
was a great experience, working
with Mauricio and being part of
this wonderful collection.
David Martin Davies: I'm David
Martin Davies.
Yvette Benavides: and I'm Yvette
Benavides, we are proud to have
contributed our journalism to
BORDERx a crisis in graphic
detail.
David Martin Davies: In my
story, water stations save
lives, Consuela Tara's
incredible artwork brought to
life the story that I found in
South Texas, where Eddie
canalis, founder of the South
Texas Human Rights Center, built
and maintains water stations in
the desert. Without them many
more immigrants would die of
thirst.
Yvette Benavides: "Kittens in
Cages" is my story which
documents how children are
forced to represent themselves
in US immigration court, and the
utter lack of concern for their
safety and their lives. Chris
doorways artwork captures the
array of emotions that I
experienced while covering the
story. Without a doubt more
people need to see these graphic
journalism stories and gain a
better understanding of the
atrocities that are happening on
America's southern border. Many
thanks to Mauricio quartetto for
spearheading this ambitious
project and making it a reality.
Samantha Stephenson: Hi, I'm
Samantha Stephenson, and I'm one
of the contributors to the
BORDERx comics anthology. It was
important to me to be part of
this project as an immigrant, I
wanted to help in some way. And
this gave me the opportunity to
to help in raising money for the
South Texas Human Rights Center.
And also to help raise awareness
about what's happening at the
border. I think for myself,
sometimes it's it's even
acknowledge the what's happening
can be so deeply and profoundly
distressing. That sometimes we
just turn away because we just
don't know what to do. It's I'm
not a lawyer, I'm not a
politician. I'm an artist and
musician. So to be given this
opportunity to actually
contribute, in some way to help
was just just great. And the
process of reading the
declarations was deeply
disturbing, to really see what
is happening there. And I think
it's important that art, whether
it be the performance arts, the
visual arts, the creative
process, to be able to bring
these things to light is very
powerful. Also, I think it's
it's really interesting to have
it as a comics Anthology,
because it's, it's something
that you can hold in your hand,
you can read in the quiet of
wherever it is that you are,
it's not a news report, in
someone else's voice, that
barrage of words being thrown at
you. And I find that perhaps
there's a certain connection
that can happen there. That can
be pretty, pretty powerful.
Donna Barr: Hi, this is Donna
Barr, and I'm speaking for
Mauricio Cordero's project his
BORDERx that will help support
actions against the treatment of
asylum seekers in the United
States, and on our borders, and
I'm the author of the desert
peach and stance. And I've done
a lot of work in comics many
projects over the years. And I
thought this was a very
worthwhile project. My one page
that I did, has to do with the
fact that we are well on our way
in to the same processes used as
in Nazi Germany, in the
treatment of asylum seekers or
people of color or women or
anybody else. It's the same
processes. And so that's what I
wanted to emphasize in my page
that I did for border x.
Tracy White: And comics are
really good, medium for activism
because you can take very
complex ideas, boil them down
and express them simply and
directly and concisely using
words and images. For example, I
think about Those little cards
that are sometimes in
restaurants or in posters about
what to do when someone's
choking, there isn't even
language, but they're
essentially a comic that is
expressing something very
complex, simply to a wide
audience. The same is true with
activism and comics, where
you're trying to get an idea
across to an audience, a variety
of ages, a variety of languages.
And this medium allows you to do
that it also allows you to
disseminate the information
electronically, it can, you
could do it in paper. And I
think that comics really taps
into the visual language that
people are used to, and can
consume easily. When I first
approached the safe passage
project, the idea for this comic
I thought it was going to be
about their clients coming to
America. So I set up a
roundtable interview with five
of their lawyers. And over the
course of those interviews, we
identified specific topics that
would be important to their
clients had, of course nothing
to do with them coming to
America, they already knew about
that. What they didn't know was,
what is a pro bono lawyer? Why
should I trust a pro bono
lawyer? What do I do if I get
suspended from school? What do I
do if I get a ticket? Very
specific questions, very
specific concerns for their
client base. After I had all
those interviews, I had them
transcribed. Then I read over
them, and using highlighters
highlighted the things that I
thought would be the most
important. Once I took all of
those highlighted things, I
boiled them down into a comic
script into a thumbnail, and I
handed them off to Peter Cooper,
who was the person who drew the
comic. And then together we made
the comic. This comic was then
disseminated within courthouses
to sister organizations across
the United States, and could be
available digitally and in comic
book form. Think BORDERx is
doing a such a great example of
comics and activism. Because
there was an idea, I want to
help immigrants, there was an
organization that was identified
to raise money for them, the
word went out within the comics
community who can help me do
this comic, many people, myself
included, can't want it to
contribute. And then you have
all these stories. And of
course, stories are the building
blocks for empathy, and without
empathy, we can't really move
forward.
Tom Hart: Hi, I'm Tom Hart.
I'm the executive director of
the sequential artists workshop.
We're a grassroots comics
organization, we're online and
in person in Gainesville,
Florida, we teach comics and
support any, any literacy and
other projects in the medium.
I've never been a very good
activist, I'm afraid, I've
always, half of me is always
wished I could be a better
activist. But the other half of
me always stays in the art world
and became an artist because I
believe in what people have to
express, and believe in
something really innate and
beautiful and interesting about
the complexity of people believe
in what people are
allowed
to do, I believe, I believe that
when people are allowed to be
themselves are allowed to
flourish when they have the
safety and the permission and
the guidance, and some
inspiration that they do most,
the most profound, interesting,
beautiful things. And so my
story in BORDERx was strange. It
was not a report Taj, it was not
a documentary, it was not trying
to show some stories that
haven't been already seen. It
was trying to investigate some
of the emotions, and some of the
backstory and
all of my stories have been
fueled by rage. rage that this
that
people aren't treated like
people, mostly that people
aren't treated like. They are
something valuable that they
have something valuable to
contribute. I've always believed
that people do and that people,
empowered by their community by
their broader world will shine
beautiful things provide
beautiful things create
beautiful things, and the
constant destruction of people's
spirits and their physical
bodies is The biggest harm
anyone can do. And we do it
constantly as a culture. And so
my stories as strange as they
are, the one in border acts as
wild as it is, is fueled by that
rage and that belief that we
should be providing for each
other.
Vivek Bald: So we're going to,
as Scot mentioned, there is a QA
that that folks who were
attendees from outside MIT can
can write their questions into
and, and we'll be opening up to
questions for from everyone on
screen right now. First, I
wanted to just step in and ask a
question to start things off,
Mauricio. And that is, uh, you
know, I'm thinking about the the
posters that were that you
showed, early on in this
presentation from the DC punk
rock scene that you were
connected to, and particularly
the poster, the rock against
Reagan poster, that was a series
of shows that happened all over
the country really, in different
punk rock scenes. And I really
have two questions connected to
that. And one is just about what
you what you learned, and what
you have sort of brought forward
as an artist from from those
origins within the DC punk
scene, which was a particularly
politically engaged scene, you
know, compared to others across
the country. And the other is
actually on a broader political
level thinking about Reagan and
thinking about what the the kind
of activism that so many were
involved in at that moment. To
tie that to the border crisis
right now, because, you know, I
think, sometimes what gets lost
in press accounts is, is the the
historical depth of, you know,
why people are fleeing from
Central America to cross the
border, which, of course, does
date back to the Reagan era. So
I was wondering if you could,
you know, the two very different
questions from looking at that
same poster, but if you could
talk about those to start off.
Mauricio Cordero: Sure. Um, so I
was lucky enough to grow up in
the punk scene. And like you
said, it was not like, the scene
in London or New York or
anywhere else, it was not
concerned with fashion, it
wasn't about having spiky
jackets, and, you know, green
hair or anything like that. It
was really about politics and
how young people can resist and,
and really rage against politics
and try to channel that into
creativity in art. Um, so, you
know, early on a one show, I
was, like, 1415, just standing
by the stage and in Mackay, and
john stab, and I believe it was
Henry Rollins walked up to me
and asked me if I was, you know,
so and so I don't remember what
the name was. And I was like,
No, but you are in, you know,
Henry and, and John Stabb, and
they were, that those were my
idols. And to have them actually
just be so approachable, sort of
shaped my attitude towards art
and music. I, I wanted to
patronize art artists who are
approachable and sort of down to
earth on and also I, I don't
have a problem with going up to
someone I admire and asking them
for something, especially when
it's for a larger cause. Um,
wow, Reagan. Um, so we did have
these wonderful shows, right
there on the Mall. At first,
they're rock against Reagan on
then rock against bush. And so
every year, around the Fourth of
July, or on the Fourth of July,
it was sort of a counter
concert, almost like the Chicago
DNC, where the MC5 played
outside to sort of counter what
was going on inside on. And
those were those were quite
formative and informative
concerts in production You know,
there'll be tons of flyers given
out but also leaflets on I first
learned about the the genocide
and Guatemala through a millions
of dead cops album MDC. They had
an insert that detailed the
atrocities and some of the most
graphic, disturbing photos that
I'd ever seen on things that
were just not being promoted in
the press, for obvious reasons.
I mean, they're, they're
gruesome photos. And so that's
sort of blunt honesty, and no
real tied to commercialism. So
the interest was getting the
truth out, maybe selling 100
albums, but really changing
minds more than having a pop
single or getting on MTV. And
the radio with Reagan, we could
talk all day all night about
Reagan in Central America. But
really, that was something that
opened my eyes, the punk rock
movement, opened my eyes to
Reagan's policies, and really
drove me to actually visit
Nicaragua in 1990, I believe, on
a small relief mission, right
after the war. But I'm not a
Latin American expert. So I'll
just kind of leave it at that.
Scot Osterweil: Thanks. Check.
Questions. Ámbar.
Ámbar Reyes: Hi, Mauricio, thank
you so much for your talk. I was
wondering, there's, there's been
a lot of conversation about like
co creating with communities.
And I was wondering, if you,
like, why did you choose to,
like, create this comic with
artists rather than, like,
commute? Like immigrant
communities, for instance, like,
create the art with those
communities? Yeah.
Mauricio Cordero: Um, well, part
of it is, you know, knowing my
skill set and how much time I
have. I make comics, I know,
professional artists, and I can
get into those circles. Um, and
I really didn't expect to spend
the entire year focused on this
one project on also, I there's
something about engaging people
that aren't engaged in that
specific topic. That's very
powerful. I would love to do
project with with migrants. And
there were some migrants
involved in border acts, and
even someone who is here without
a without papers, but I won't
get too much into that. Um,
however, they already know the
history, they know what's
happening, what's happening to
them, how they're seen by
society. And so I thought,
opening it up to other people
who might not know, as Jim
points out in the video, there
are a lot of teams. And so you
know, for some of the comments,
we had up to seven people
working on a comic, all looking
at this topic and all learning
from it and really absorbing it.
And if I could create a few more
advocates for the border crisis
issues, I felt that it was a
good strategy and and they
further reached out to their
audiences and sort of got the
word much further than I could
have done on my own. Does that
make sense?
Ámbar Reyes: Yeah. Thank you.
Thank you.
Scot Osterweil: Javier?
Javier Barroso: Hello, everyone.
Nice to thank you for for your
presentation and for for the
project. My question is, do you
you see any value in perhaps
offering a translated version of
the Scientology to Spanish? It
seemed feasible even or have you
thought about it?
Mauricio Cordero: Um, yes. And
I've done it. So one of the
things that I didn't fit into
the video is that we had a team
of translators who I knew one of
them when I lived in France and
he got a large group in
Barcelona to take every single
page and translate it. So
obviously, um, you know, or
audiences Latin American. So
they worked with a few editors,
I believe in Arizona and one in
Mexico, to proofread it to take
the sort of Castilian aspect out
and translate it into more
universal Spanish on. So part of
those have a few of those have
gone out to artists, the rest
are sitting on my hard drive
until tomorrow, when I have time
again to work on this. And we
hope to get a new, all Spanish
edition out. Um, I'd like to try
to do another fundraiser or
somehow figure out a way to fund
the printing so we can get them
into the remain in Mexico camps,
physical copies. So we have a
few leads, there's a nun who's
doing some incredible work on
the border on like smuggling,
reading materials and things
into the camps. And so, you
know, it's it's an ongoing
process, but it's, it's not
complete. And it's kind of time
consuming, as well to redo the
lettering. But luckily, we don't
have to redo the art. So it'll
be forthcoming. Thank you.
Javier Barroso: Thank you.
Scot Osterweil: Other questions?
Vivek Bald: Well, I will, until
we have another question. I had
another question that was more
about process. And that is I'm
curious to hear about the
relationship a bit more about
the relationship between this
project the the project, I'm
forgetting the name of the woman
who was speaking about Project
Amplify, and the southern Texas
human rights group. And what
what were the connections
between all three? You know, you
mentioned in the, in the talk
that you were already working on
the project before connecting
with Project Amplify, but I'm
also interested in the
connection with with the South
Texas human rights group.
Mauricio Cordero: Feels like I
almost woke up one morning, just
thinking is anybody paying
attention. And as I explored,
just google searches and
whatnot, I can't come across
Project Amplify. And I think
someone might have pointed me
the way and I reached out to
them. And that's when we struck
up a sort of partnership on part
of the box. So they supplied the
verbatim transcripts that were
presented to the Supreme Court
in Florida versus bar. And I
sifted through those and gave
them out to artists teams to
illustrate on and after that,
they've just been so supportive.
Warren binford is someone who I
can call at any point and just
ask her to try to, you know, get
the word out there or other
things. She was instrumental in
getting a Senator Jeff Merkley
on board, he wrote the prologue
to the addition. And finally, on
the south Texas Human Rights
Center, on you know, I estimated
that this project would make
maybe a few hundred to a few
thousand dollars on not much
more. And as I was thinking,
Okay, so I'll direct the money
to races. Like just days after
that they did a Facebook post
and raised $12 million off of a
single Facebook post. And I
just, I thought, I don't want to
take all this artwork, this all
these hours of work and raise,
you know, a drop in the ocean, I
set out to find a very small,
very lean, nonprofit. And so I
consulted GuideStar and look for
extremely small budgets. And I
came across an ACLU listing of
underfunded projects doing a
central work on the border. And
that's when I found three
organizations. And for various
reasons, two of them just were
like comics on and Eddie was
just great. He's like, yeah,
gung ho, let's do it on. And
also the mission is it's a
difficult one. And I like
problems, I guess. It's hard to
convince someone to fund an
organization that provides water
for migrants who are crossing
the border, but also on forensic
recovery. It's, it's difficult
to talk about, it's
uncomfortable. And you know,
it's it's hard to pitch. So that
attracted me I, I wanted to
challenge I wanted people to be
aware of what we're really
talking about, and it's life and
death. And so that's how I
decided on South Texas Human
Rights Center.
Scot Osterweil: Heather, you had
a question?
Heather Hendershot: Yeah. Um, I
have two questions. The The
first one is, you mentioned
early on your decision, to not
mention the name of he who must
not be named throughout the
whole work. And I wonder if you
could talk more about why you
made that decision and how
important it was to the project?
Um, and my other question is
less political, more just
aesthetic, because we saw such
an interesting range of styles.
And I wonder if you could talk
about just a bit more about
their decision to use all these
different visual styles. And,
and you know, one moment I even
noticed the back of the current
president's head, and it looks
really like Gary Trudeau draws
that hair, like, thing, mongoose
sort of device on that person's
head. So that was a moment, I
saw a direct sort of influence
of like, Oh, yeah, I've seen
work that looks like this
before. And other things. I was
like, I haven't seen anything
that looked like this, you know,
it was really unique. So I
wonder if you could just talk a
little bit about the aesthetics.
Mauricio Cordero: The aesthetics
is simple, I just put the
project out there. And I don't
know how I got so lucky. The
artwork that came back was just
really top notch, and really
professional. And the sort of
variety that I wanted, I, you
know, early on, I considered for
about two seconds, doing my own
book before I even thought of
doing an anthology. And I
thought, No, it would be one
point of view to be one voice.
And it would be limited by my
reach my my scope on so I really
wanted to, to do the project in
a way that had multiple
different viewpoints, styles,
approaches, and points of view.
So that was the aesthetic bit,
I'm not mentioning it. Um, so
that person thrives on
attention. And we don't need to
give it any more attention than
it gets with a tweak. Um. Also,
I'm just continuously
frustrated. So I was going to
include this in the
presentation, but then it's just
getting too long. For a little
while I was doing a comic based
on on that person's antics, and
I couldn't keep it up. As soon
as I finished a comic, the issue
was irrelevant, because it was
replaced by another issue, you
know, firing. So if I spent
hours drawing this one person, a
week later, they're out of the
administration on in the same
sort of dynamic was happening
with some of these important
issues that we were losing the
thread on the migrant crisis,
because he was doing some other
clown show or grabbing a pony
and balancing ball on his nose,
and all these other ridiculous
things that he does to get
attention. So I really didn't
want his inclusion in this
volume to take away any of the
energy or attention from where
it should be on the individuals
who are actually affected by
this crisis. And we didn't
negotiate that. That one image
that you mentioned, I think
there might be two appearances
in the book. And I asked in the
artists were very polite and
accommodating, to not show his
face and to not write him His
name out way. And and I'm glad
for it. No regrets. I think he's
implicated enough by his
policies and actions that we
don't need to name or depict him
anymore.
Vivek Bald: there's a there's a
question from from the chat from
Caitlin. Mauricio, thank you for
inviting your SAW colleagues to
this important discussion. How
have the children whose stories
are amplified in this project
responded to seeing the comics?
Mauricio Cordero: Well, we don't
know. Um, the all the testimony
is anonymous, for various
reasons for the protection of
the children on so I don't know
if any of the children in the
exhibits has actually seen the
comic. And that is what I had
hoped to do on later on is try
to find a few agencies that can
distribute the electronic
version and the Spanish version.
Um, but sadly, we just can't get
that sort of feedback.
Scot Osterweil: Other questions?
a question over here.
Sajan Saini: Hi Mauricio. I'm
visitor to the lecture. Very
impressive work. I'm curious,
ask your thought having
completed the work and looking
back at it at this point? How do
you situate the decisions that
you made for one reason or the
other upfront to go with as an
independent work? And even
thinking at the outset about a
sort of a punk rock perspective,
if you will, right, governing
the aesthetic, but what's been
realized now, the work they have
in front of you. I'm curious to
get your thought about how you
see it having similarity or
dissimilarity to the kind of
stuff Joe Sacco has done right.
years ago. curious to hear your
thoughts about that and how you
see sort of the elasticity of
comics to do this kind of work.
Mauricio Cordero: Oh, wow. Joe
Sacco. Um, I think that harks
back to, I love his work. I love
what he's done. I'm not a
journalist. I'm not trained in
journalism. I'm not a historian.
I make comics. So I wouldn't. It
just wouldn't be my my
wheelhouse to try to do a sort
of in depth project on the
border on however, I have
opinions, and I have Google so.
So I can't find enough
information to provide my
viewpoint. But really, going
back to that punk aesthetic, it
was a very inclusive movement.
You know, if you had a band that
had been rehearsing for three
weeks in a basement in Falls
Church or Alexandria, you could
be on a stage with minor threat
or you know, later on fougasse,
or some of the key bands on. So
I think this this inclusive
spirit, permeated through the
BORDERx anthology, some of the
artists are actually first time
comic creators a lot of the
longer pieces. I sort of ripped
out of the hands of writers who
are like, well, I've never
written a comic before. And I
was like, No, no, it'll be okay,
come on. And so we sort of coach
them on how to translate their
script into comic book form. For
example, Brian DeLay, he had
never done a comic, but was
really really enthused by
comics. So, um, see, I think, by
providing a large platform,
getting a lot of different
voices, and it just harkens back
to that DIY spirit. I'm sorry.
Did I answer your question.
Sajan Saini: That's good. Thank
you. Thanks. Merci.
Scot Osterweil: Thanks.
Questions?
Jim Paradis: I just want to make
a comment. I think Joe Sacco
would love this comic. Joe Sacco
has a new workout title paying
the land that just came out
about a year ago, but this is
very much Maurico's a cousin
This is this is the same real
and I think these two comi
artists would be very, ver
compart compatible. And yeah, s
anyway, that's interesting t
mention that because that's als
art that has advocacy. But it'
it's art that is formed in
different way, but very, ver
similar. So anyway, it's it'
worth mentioning. That's nice
nice comparison
Mauricio Cordero: If anyone has
just Sacco's address, I'm happy
to send him a copy.
Scot Osterweil: So I have a
question, Mauricio. I think
about sort of having been
outraged by the same things you
outraged over the years. And one
of the things that overall, I've
come to realize is that, how
little at least I don't know
whether it was ever, ever
otherwise, but how little
accountability there is over
time. In other words, no one's
paid. No one's paid a penalty
for what the Reagan
administration did in Latin
America, no one's paid a
penalty. D for what's happened
in happened in Iraq in the first
decade of this century. Any
thoughts about whether we can
whether I mean, it's it's
critical that we're, you're
doing what you're doing to raise
awareness of the the problems?
Is there any thought about a
role I could have in terms of
actually trying to bring people
to account I guess,
Mauricio Cordero: I'm sorry,
kind of bring people
Scot Osterweil: bring people to
account for their crimes? Yeah.
Mauricio Cordero: Wow. Um, you
know, it's tough now with
without getting mystical or
anything like that I
we recently saw a Shepard Fairey
on exhibit in Los Angeles. And
it was wonderful to revisit
scumbags like Nixon and Reagan
in all their awfulness on. And
so I think that's part of what
artists who create political art
do is they, they preserve the
ugliness, they look away, they
look straight into that storm
and say, you know, we're
watching, and we're recording
it. And that was one of the
goals with BORDERx is to try to
create something of quality that
would endure past this
administration, and hey, guess
what, in just like, what 60
days, BORDERx will have endured
past this administration, and it
remains an account of some of
the atrocities But to be clear,
on the border migration crisis
has been going on well, before
this credit.
So, you know,
there's a lot of accountability
to spread around there. Yeah.
Vivek Bald: Okay, well,
we're up on 630. So I just
wanted to with everyone, thank
you so much for your time and
and for for the putting together
the presentation and and I look
forward to being able to to read
to read the to read BORDERx. And
actually, that's, that's a
question and to end with it, how
how can we all get our hands on
physical copies of BORDERx,
Mauricio Cordero: BORDERx? It's
really available through any
retailer, mostly online, you
know, fully stocked on the
shelves. But if you go to www
order hyphen x.com on you can
order it through the big players
like Amazon and Barnes and
Nobles, but also through a books
through indie bound through all
the smaller distributors and
their links on the website to
the smaller distributors. And
the best thing honestly, is just
call up your local bookstore and
do like a curbside pickup, you
know, and, and just support
them. They need it, especially
the comic book stores. They're
really taking a hit. So if
you're here in Somerville,
Kamikaze is wonderful place.
They've been very supportive.
And yeah, support your local
worksheets, please.
Vivek Bald: All right. Thank you
so much. And thank you, everyone
for joining us tonight. All
right.
Mauricio Cordero: Bye.